[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
let's start with Jessica in Boston
what's going on
Jessica hi so I'm wondering how uh my
husband and I have we're a family of
five we have three kids five and under
we both work we we make a very good
living north of 300K a year which almost
50 of it is tax-free um because my
husband receives the ages of
pay um monthly but we are we've had
several crisis crisises I guess come up
the past two years um and we were debt
free but now we've due to the unexpected
occurrences um we're now living beyond
our means paycheck to paycheck have no
savings and you know um our emotional
our physical health is taking a toll our
marriage is taking a toll um and we we
want to stop living paycheck to paycheck
how do we get out of this
um and how can we repair the
relationship along the
way I'm sorry to hear what you're going
through yeah what happened what were the
crises yeah so we um the height of the
real estate market right we we sold our
first house you know this is our
opportunity to get debt free we were
probably I want to say between 50 to
65,000 in debt um at the height of the
market in 2021 we sold our first home uh
walked away Spot Free um paid off the
entirety of our debt um and then I got
pregnant with our third child I was only
six months postpartum um and I was
actually struggling with postpartum
depression in in theum um I had we had
major complications I was in pre-term
labor for almost three months um
and I am the breadwinner between me and
him um very high- pressured you know uh
software uh sales technology sales I
should say um job and which forced me to
uh need to take a a medical leave of
absence due to my postpartum getting so
bad um it was literally for the safety
of myself and my family that I had to
take a medical leave and the day I
returned to work I was laate off um and
turn we literally two weeks yeah it was
bad so two I want to say a month prior
to me going back to work uh we had just
closed on a new home uh our forever home
and the bills piled up quick so how much
debt are you in
now it's
probably I want to say between 22 to
25,000 total and what kind of
debt yeah so it's unsecured loan debt
credit card debt um should I include the
car or no yes that's debt isn't it okay
then it goes up from there so I would
tack on a total an additional 60 an
addition so you're probably $85,000 in
consumer are you are you back to working
now I am I am I found a new job fairly
soon within a month um and I am working
are you still making 300,000 it takes
some time to build the pipeline again
okay what what what's your husband
do yeah he works um for the government
um and he was a marine and now he works
for the government as a safety inspector
okay for OSHA so I'm gonna let George
talk you through this this debt
situation but I want to say a couple
things okay okay the first thing is I'm
really really glad you're still
here thank you appreciate that making
that call when you're holding a baby is
one of the scariest calls you can make
right it is yeah because there's that
demon telling you that um they're going
to take your baby away people are going
to say you're crazy and they're gonna
lock you up and I'm so so proud of you
for doing that that's
hard and we're good now
right for the most most of the time I
still have moments yes there you go um
let me ask you this way you're always
going to be around here
right yes for sure good um the second
thing is
if you haven't already there's going to
come a moment when yall are going to
have to and the quicker you get here the
quicker you can begin to do the walk the
path that Jordan's going to lay out for
you you're going to have to make peace
with grieve the crap out of but make
peace with here's the life we had and
now here's the one we're in right
now okay the more you try to quote
unquote get back to what we had the more
you're going to make yourself nuts cuz
you're just going to run in a Circle
you're going to be dragging what used to
be right so we used to have $60,000 cars
we don't anymore we're a Camry family
now we used to have a humongous house
and we had our forever house it's not
our forever house anymore you and me are
forever husband but the house isn't and
that's okay okay and we used to make 300
Grand now we don't and maybe one day we
will again but that's not the world
we're in right now and so when you make
peace existentially with those moments
then remember we had Alexis yeah but now
we got now we got a Corolla and it gets
us where we need to go and you got a
bunch of dope Marine tattoos but you're
going to look awesome smoking hot
getting out of a Camry that's just the
world we have now right yeah and it's
not less than it's just different it's
different and it'll be back it'll be
back you're a you're a hustler your
husband's a brilliant guy I mean you'll
be back but let's make peace with that
new world right and that new world is
Awesome by the way it's top 1% of planet
Earth it's a great world just we got to
let go of what used to be used to be
awesome and then we got laid off and it
sucks and here we are now now it's
awesome again just a different kind of
awesome okay so Jessica this is going to
start with some simple math but it's
going to end with some sacrifice and
behavior change you ready for it
absolutely keep mind is is your husband
on board too this is an important factor
he is he knows how you feel about all
this okay we're going to get you to
Solid Ground and I'll give you some
options it'll be a Choose Your Own
Adventure my guess is your take home pay
is somewhere around 15 grand a
month
uh yes okay correct so let's look at
what our expenses are what do we need to
keep the household running and you're
going to do that with a budget I'm going
to gift it to you it's called every
dollar I'm going to give you the premium
version it's going to have paycheck
planning connect to your bank account
all the good stuff your homework is to
list out every single expense you have
as a family and ruthlessly cut out the
stuff that doesn't matter that you don't
need right now you got that okay give me
a rough estimate of what that would add
up to five
grand for cutting out or the essential
the total expenses that would keep the
house running food shelter utilities
Transportation all
that probably 12 12
Grand yep with our Nanny included Child
Care
included okay this is where remember
those sacrifices I mentioned Jessica
this is where we might have to figure
out how to get that 12 Grand down to
five so we have 10,000 to throw at the
debt and we can be done in 8 months that
might mean selling the cars if you can't
make those sacrific being letting the NY
go for a season this is not going to be
fun but your life on the other side is
going to be way better for it create
your free every dooll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life